this program is being presented to you
by the Harris international winter
school on gravity and lights
welcome to the problem class of the w/e
year's international winter school on
gravity in light today with our tenth
problem sheet about symmetries we as
always start with the first exercise
true or false which statements about
push forward and pull back are correct
the push forward maps a vector field to
a vector field this statement is not
correct therefore I have to remind you
on the definition of the push forward
first of all we have a manifold M with a
map Phi 2 n this map only has to be
smooth no injectivity nothing else said
about that these are our both many
faults now we take a point P and around
that the tangent space TPM and we take
another point Q and the tension space
over there now it could be that the map
file met the point Q and P to the same
point in the manifold M since the push
forward is a map from T M 2 T M we
always get with and this map is defined
with respect to this map we always get
the tangent vector in TN but the idea of
a vector field is that we have at each
point of the manifold to draw it again
this is now M
and these are the tangent vectors the
tension spaces over there we always have
just one vector in each tensioned vector
space but with this construction we had
two points in one of these tension
spaces therefore it's not a vector field
therefore the first answer is incorrect
the pullback of a Cove active Co vector
yields a co vector I remind you on the
definition of this we can again have
this picture but the Popek maps from t
star m2 t star m and this is certainly
true then every element in T star M lies
especially in 1tv pie and and maps it to
one t star PI M therefore it Maps a co
vector to a co vector this answer is
correct one can use a metric on a
smoothly embedded manifold by pulling
the metric back from the ambient
manifold this is correct and assure you
one we just define it in the lectures we
just say that the pull back of a metric
evaluated on some vector fields is
defined as the following it's G of the
push forward of the vectors and this
defines the pull back of the metric
therefore this statement is also true
the pull back
I should clarify what an embedding us
first so an embedding is a map
it's injective map from a manifold to
another manifold and embedding we just
denote by this curved arrow this have to
be smooth then it's a smooth and
injective then it's a smooth embedding
if we have this we always can find such
a map and this is always fulfilled the
next question asked us about other push
forward and pull back linear maps yes
they are
that's correct and I show you a part of
the proof here we again have the map 5
from say M to n and we now want to see
how this works so let act push forward
on a sum of two vectors after that this
lies in TP T Phi of P n so we have to
act on a function f which is an element
of C infinity M for this construction we
need that x and y are element of the
same tangent space otherwise this
addition what is not well defined for
that we use the definition its X plus y
of F after 5 but now this is again the
different the addition on the TPM but
since TPM is a vector space we know the
defined point was in this sense
and after that we can again apply the
definition of the push forward what is
Phi star X of F plus Phi star Y of F we
can now again pull out the F and what we
see that it is linear the same trick we
can do for if we multiply with a
constant out of our we will see that it
works the same way therefore the push
forward is linear and we can also do
with the same calculation for the pull
back and therefore in shorthand push
forward and pull back are both linear
maps in this sense the push forward is a
1 1 10 so this is incorrect since a 1 1
tensor is a map from T star M cross T M
into the rears in a multi linear fashion
this is not the definition of a push
forward one can only pull back a 1 1
tensor along a buy checked if map this
is incorrect one can actually pull back
any tensor along a patch active map
therefore the answer is incorrect B
which statements are correct
Aliza algebra L is a symmetry of a
metric tensor field Chi if the poor back
of Chi along the flow of any element of
L reproduces team first we clarify the
vector field ok we have if we have a
vector field X which looks like that
then it has intricate integral curves
that means that they exist curves in the
manifold which point P where the vectors
of the curve at this point coincide with
the vectors of the vector field at this
point that's it and now we can ask or we
can we we can look whether if we start
here and go with the with the integral
curve gamma P just a small parameter
value of lambda we come to this point
and at that point the tangent vector of
this curve should also agree with the
tangent of the vector field okay that's
it and if we we can do this for all
points in the manifold here or peace and
we come after a small step lambda always
to another point here and all this maps
we denoted by H with respect to X the
vector field with respect to the
parameter lambda is a map from M to M in
a smooth fashion this we called the flow
map since this is a smooth map between
two many many faults we can push forward
or pull back some tensile feel some
tensors along this curve so if we now do
age X lambda pullback of symmetric and
this yields again the metric that means
if we start here and see our here's
metric attached and we go back some
steps and see our the metric has the
same it looks totally the same then we
know the vector field x is a symmetry of
the metric G and if this holds for all
vector fields out of the leads of
algebra then we call the lead sub
algebra a symmetry of the Mack metric
tensor field Chi
this statement is correct the leader
riveted of a vector field why with
respect to a vector field X is the
commutator X Y we just record the second
axiom of the leader relative L X Y and
it was defined as X comma Y with the
commutator so this statement is true
Alys up algebra l is a symmetry of a
metric tensor field if the leader
relative of Chi with respect to every X
element L Venice's therefore we just
have to repeat how the linear relative
was defined we can define L X of some
Chi is defined as the limit lambda
against 0 H X lambda star of Qi minus Qi
divided with lambda a through lambda but
from the first question we know already
that this is equal to this so the
nominator is a 0 therefore this is a
zero therefore if the leader rivet if
with respect to X of T is 0 therefore it
means that L is a symmetry of the metric
this statement is also correct the
leader rivet --iv acts on a function as
the covariant derivative does this is
simply the first axiom of the leader
rivet if it says LX f equals to X of F
and this is the same as the covariant
derivative therefore this statement is
also correct and we finished the first
exercise
exercise to pull back and push forward
formula for practical man and women
question consider a smooth map 5 from M
to M between two differentiable
manifolds show that for function f
elements C infinity n the pullback of
the gradient of F is the same as the
gradient of the pullback of F that means
exactly this yeah in order to show that
we choose an X element TPM which on
which we act with the whole guy here
since V Star DF is the element of T P
star M we can act on a TPM and get a
real number let's do that as first step
we just apply the definition of the
pullback it is the vector R the Kovach
to field acting on the push forward of
the vector field first definition second
definition we just use the definition of
the gradient that is five put forward of
X what is again an element of TPM what
can act on a function C infinity n this
is this guy as a next step we use the
definition of the push forward this is
defined as X after F of Phi now we have
to think a little bit in order to get
exactly this form we can ask ourselves
what is the push forward of a func air
what is the pull back of a function
therefore I will draw a short picture
mm5 and we feel the function f into our
we can ask now what what we already know
is if we pull back in this way Cove
extra fields we again get a CO vector
field over em what we now considers that
if we put back a function on em we want
to get back a function on em this is the
only thing we can get out of this
structure this is the map F after Phi Y
and to write this in a pullback fashion
we write it down as the pour back of the
function f okay with this thoughts done
we can insert this in here now it's
written X after Phi star of F and we now
go some steps backwards we know that
this can also be written with the
definition of the gradient as G of the
function Phi star of the F what is in
all a function on C infinity M acting on
the vector of X X therefore as we see
since we did this all for an arbitrary
vector X we can conclude that this is
equivalent to Phi star DF equals to D
Phi star F this is exactly what we have
to show
question two the push forward from TM to
TM it's a linear map between tension
bundles calculate its components
function ok so in order to do that we
just apply this thing just calculate
some steps and see that the result of
that is very important to derive this
formula V Star a beam equals 2d y a
acting on V Star del after del X P we
first apply the definition the gradient
again that's the vector V star of Dell
after del X P what lies in TN acting
acting on why a but where Y a is a
function on n since Y a are the charts
on N and we just can use the definition
of the performer again that means it's
vector file field D after DX P acting on
why a after Phi this is all what we want
to do at this step
question show that the component
functions of the pull back fist Archie
of a metric tensor field are obtained
from the component functions of G by the
following expression therefore we just
have to calculate a little bit and use
the result of question two so let's
start
Phee star g
a be evaluated at P in the X chart is
defined as the following its P star G of
become the basis and not allowed to
forget the brackets here because we have
to evaluate at P but as we have seen
before as we know from the lectures that
the pullback of the metric is the push
forward as the metric evaluated at the
push forward of its arguments therefore
next definition G of 5 star acting on
Dell after del X evaluated at P comma
Phi star del after del X being evaluated
P bracket closed so after this we simply
can expand our Chi again
we can expand the vectors inside the Chi
in some basis we call this basis why
it's Chi off first we need the
components of a vector del of del X
evaluated at P the enth component times
the basis vector evaluated at P comma
Phi star surely not a pie there's a 5
pie since after we do the push forward
we go from M to n and the bases are then
in free pie it's C star of del after del
X be evaluated at P there from the enth
component of del of the Del Y n
evaluated at Phi of the PI big break it
close since we know that G is a linear
map we just can pull out the coefficient
functions here and the coefficient
functions here so let's do that
it's Phi star of del Del X a related P
the nth component
times Phi star of Dell of the Dell X P
evaluated at P from that the enth
component times G of Dell after del Y M
evaluated at five pile come on Dell
after Del Y M evaluated at five PI this
guy here is just Chi M M evaluated at
five PI in the wide shot and the first
guy and the second guy - well we just
have to see how this two relations are
come together we know that if we want if
we like to figure out the components of
a vector and these are the components of
a vector we have to act on the vector
itself with the dual basis therefore we
can write this expression as del Y M
acting on Phi star off tell after del X
evaluated P pretty close break it close
and this is exactly this guy ah but this
we already calculated and we see that's
just del after del X B X Y of Phi with
this index combination we just have to
re look for the right index combination
and write it down
after seen that this is exactly what we
calculate in question two over here we
just can plug in these guys and for
these guys we can plug in this so what
written here is L after del X a evaluate
at P of Y after Phi from this the enth
component times del after del X P
evaluated at P and from that Y after
five the enth component from behind we
have this G M n in the Y's chart Phi of
Pi and comparing to what is written here
we see that this is true therefore this
exercise is complete we now come to
exercise 3 ly derivative the pedestrian
way the leader rivet if as a tool for
investigating symmetries question
consider the smooth embedding yata as a
map from s2 to r3 off as - equipped with
the topology in the atlas so a smooth
manifold and the same for r3 which for
families theoretical child u comma X
element a and R 3 comma Y is the
identity map on r3 is given by the
following expression where a and B are
positive real numbers what can you say
about the shape of yata of s2 that's a
good question what is the shade
first of all I would say it is necessary
to can talk about straight lines or
something like this but as we already
found out in order to do that we it's
not enough to have a pair smooth
manifold we need extra structure there
we we just know in this course we just
know two extra structures it's on the
one hand side a connection which yields
something like that
or on the other hand side it's a metric
but since we do not have anything like
this define them this smooth manifold
air three or standard and B we could not
talk about the shape therefore what can
you say about the shape of your toe
Festool the antler is nothing question
two now assume that our three or
standard beam is additionally equipped
with the akkadian metric team whose
component functions with respect to the
chart are three why are given by this
expression right down the component
factions of qi ellipsoid which is
defined by the pullback of G with
respect to the transmission function
gutter with respect to the chart G of X
okay how does this work we just have to
simply recall the formula of the last
exercise of exercise 2 therefore we
found out that the port back the
components of the port back of a metric
I just defined as the following this is
just the definition again evaluated at
some point and just the component
functions but the formula we found out
was that this is equivalent to del of
why I should
right down the similar way as before
then after del X a related P of Y of
yatta the N component times del after
del X be evaluated a paean of y of yatta
the nth component component multiplied
with GM n of I of P not I'm sorry Yatta
Yatta of P okay
but this symbols we can simply expand a
little bit more we know that this symbol
just translate the first one as the
partial derivative with respect to the
eighth component of Y of yatta of x
inverse of X of P from that the nth
component the second derivative is del P
of Y of yatta of X inverse the nth
component of X of P times GM n yota of P
but let's have a quick look look at yota
of P we know ah this is just in the
manifold r3 so at this point something
is going wrong since this P over here is
not the same PS here I'm sorry it's just
confusing I'm very very sorry
on this p8 cultures people here or peace
go to Pete will and all the P twiddles
our element of s 2 so our yatta maps our
elements of s 2 into 3 and the in the
sense that i of p twiddle is equals to
PI therefore we can use here it's just a
pie just correct it here GM n of Pi and
therefore we can use the concrete
expression of the Chi in the ambient
space okay that's the first step in
order to now really calculate how all
the components of Chi ellipsoid look
like we just have to calculate a and B
are running in this case from 1 to 2 so
1 2 ok we just plug in I write it down
one time a little bit a little bit more
and then I just talk about what I'm
doing here it's the nth component
derived with respect to the first
component of Y of yata of X inverse of X
of Pi there one y of yata of X inverse
the nth component immediately right in
here of X of P tilde times G M and P so
what I see first is if M is not equal to
n all this terms vanish so we have to
just do y equals 1 it was 1 equals 2
equals 2 equal 3 equal 3 that means we
get here three terms but all terms a
quadratic of one of these balls because
these are the same since the derivatives
are the same here
okay look at the first term and the good
thing is that this expression is given
here so we can now just derive if you
derive with respect to the first
components we just derived with respect
to theta and if we derive with respect
to the second component we just derived
with respect of fire okay let's do that
and the first thing it yields a squared
cosine squared Phi times cosine squared
theta theta plus B squared times sine
squared of Phi times cosine squared of
theta times C squared of sine squared of
theta
but in this expression since a B and C
are not the same in principle we cannot
go any further the same calculation
holds now for G lips arrayed 1/2 of P
tilde and after a short calculation you
will find out that it's the same as a
squared cosine Phi cosine theta times
with a minus sine Phi sine theta plus B
squared sine Phi cosine theta times sine
theta cosine Phi since we know that a
metric has to be symmetric we also know
that this is the same as G 2 1 lip side
P tilde if you don't believe me
calculated again and you will see the
same G ellipsoid to two yields after
short calculation a squared sine squared
Phi sine squared theta plus B squared
cosine squared Phi sine square theta
that is all we are asked to do in this
question but what we see here is it's
very interesting if we have given a
leading metric on the r3 we can
construct from there given an embedding
map which embeds the s2 into the s3 we
can pull back the metric from the whole
r3 that's the idea of this exercise and
you see the formulas are not very short
but ke and it's really easy to calculate
question for convenience denote by theta
and Phi the coordinate functions x1 and
x2
check that the vector field given here
constitute a list of algebra of gamma T
squared with the leave bracket determine
its tracks structure constants one is a
Lisa algebra a Lisa algebra can be
perfect paraphrased that if we take two
objects out of the algebra taking the
leader riveted of it should yield a
linear combination of the lie algebra
components where the cka chain had just
some factors if we have checked this we
can be sure that all axioms which has to
be satisfied from the algebra are
satisfied and while this calculation we
also get the structure constants we
start
with the first bracket we just take x1
x3 evaluate at some point then we have a
vector and if you have a vector we can
act with it on a function f and this we
just do in order to do not forget any
terms afterwards we will see that the
function f pull out here is something
written and all the equation holds just
for the x1 come back three okay let's
start
it's X after x3 of P on F minus x3 after
x1 at P of F this is equal to x1 after
x3 x3 is easy x1 is just this guy it's
minus sine of fine till after del theta
minus cotangent theta cosine Phi del Del
Phi acting on them after they'll file
after that we evaluate all this at P and
act on a function f minus or the guy the
other way around
they'll Delphi
acting on - - we pick 2 times a - make a
plus here sine Phi del after del theta
minus cotangent theta cosine Phi del
after Delphi after acting with a vector
field on a vector field we evaluate at a
point
and act on function f so what is what is
happening here first the first
derivative acts on this function and
after that we act with the other two
derivatives on the function which comes
out if we act with derivatives or a
function that means what is written here
is minus sign del after del theta del
Del Phi of P EF minus cotangent theta
cosine Phi del del Phi del Del Phi of F
and we also have to evaluate all these
points then since we already do the a
variation on P and over here I forgot a
Phi sine Phi of P of P of P and I will
suppress the piece from now on second
term here we have to be a little bit
more carefully since we act with the
derivative on a product of function sine
Phi del Del Phi on F it's a product and
it acts on both so its first the
derivative of sine and Phi with respect
to Phi is just cosine Phi del Del theta
of F plus sine Phi del square del P del
theta on F minus first derived the
cosine
and it did again of minds and minus sign
mistakes since I said here I bring the
minus out and forgot it in this term I'm
sorry
so again they'll Delphi on this guy if
you derive cosign take the derivative of
cosign it's cold tension
theta sine Phi del del Phi on F plus
cotangent theta cosine Phi del squared
down 5/5 on F what one sees now is that
Delta Phi F with this guy the same
component in front though this kicks out
this you also see is that this guy and
this guy are the same with another sign
so this kicks out the only two terms
which are still there at these two guys
that's cosine Phi del del find F minus
cotangent theta sine Phi del Del Phi on
F and what I mentioned before us we act
with both objects we act with both
things on F so we can bring out the F
and what is written there is exactly the
sky the x2 term so what we get in the
end this is equivalent to X 1 X 3 are
equal to 1 times X 2
and destruction coefficient function is
a 1 you can now do the same calculation
for all remaining pairs and with the C
it works out very well this is a
take-home exercise for you the next
question calculate the integral curve of
x3 through the point P equal to inverse
of X equal to X inverse of theta naught
Phi naught that means the curve gamma P
satisfying as an integral graph it has
to satisfy gamma P of 0 is P that means
for the value lambda is 0 we start at
the point P and let the tangent of the
curve gamma p at some point gamma P of
lambda is the same as the vector field
x3 evaluated at gamma P of lambda that
means that point wise the tangent vector
of the curve and the vector field share
the same vector component okay just
repeat what we mean by an interior curve
or a curve in general in a chart it's
just X after lambda X after gamma from
lambda off to explain to you how a curve
looks in a chart I will write out these
two expressions again it's just X gamma
Prime the East come if component times
del X I this is the left hand side from
the right hand side I know
this is also just the summer of this
guy's and I write this more precisely in
our fashion it's since we know X 1 theta
and X 2 is 5 it's just fine
theta sorry after gamma prime times del
Del theta plus 5 gamma prime del Del Phi
is equal to big 3 component the vector
field X 3 at this point and the vector
field is given by del after Del Phi ah
what we can immediately read off is that
this guy has to be 0 and this guy has to
be 1 Prime and I didn't I just suppress
that I evaluate Atlanta sorry of lambda
equals to 0 and Phi of gamma of lambda
is equal to 1 but this is not asked now
we want to calculate this guy in order
to get this we have to integrate this ok
the integration for one dimensional
problems very easy especially if the
right side is ur 0 so what we get is a
theta
after gamma of lambda is some constant
but we know I just to first the both
integrations on the this side it nearly
is simple it's just 5 after gamma of
lambda
it's 1 times lambda plus another
constant C Prime
but since we now have the boundary
conditions
yeah gamma PI of 0 is PI we have to plug
in this give me a quick thinking about
that we know that pi is x inverse of
theta not fine not so theta
after gamma naught we know from that
that this is just theta naught and from
five times gamma zero we know lambda is
taken to zero so this is just V naught
therefore we get that C is theta naught
and the tilde is Phi naught Phi naught
and Phi after gamma of lambda is equal
to lambda plus Phi naught therefore we
have calculate the integral curve gamma
P in a charge X question the integral
curves gamma P gives rise to a
one-parameter family of smooth maps edge
egg three lambda from s 2 to s to
calculate the poor back edge three
lambda star chillip side of the metric
on s2 what can you conclude for the
leader riveted LX 3 of G first of all
let us think about what this map is
doing therefore we choose a chart
X after H X 3 lambda after X inverse is
a map from r2 to r2 in the following
sense we plug in just theater and a file
and what we get all this theta 5 plus
lambda if you like to draw a picture of
the sphere embedded in ss3 this is s2
with the crowd somehow here then the
vector fields x3 adjust these lines here
to the equator then one line here and so
on and so on
it's just cyclic and what our or map
does is just if you start at this point
say after some parameter lambda we just
change the Phi of you know with respect
to this parameter lambda so we run
around the quarter or other lines here
okay this is the idiom and
and what can you conclude for the leader
relative L with respect to X 3 of Chien
we're cheese mean the chillip so it
means if this would be equal to the Chi
ellipse it again then the metric would
look the same all on all lines along the
quarter or parallel lines to that okay
in order to check this we have to
calculate a little bit therefore we have
to calculate the poor bag age x3 lambda
of Chi ellipsoid but this we just want
to calculate the components of that and
therefore we have to evaluate in s2 and
s2 we get if you take the inverse map X
inverse of Theta Phi so first step is
again use the result of exercise to how
a metric pulls back under some flow
it's just del Del X a of X after h x3
lambda I forgot to evaluate this at the
point there from this we have the nth
component exactly in our point P is
again like here X inverse of theta of
five times del after del X B X after h
x3 lambda the nth component the
derivative evaluated at X minus theta 5
times Chi M a of
age egg three lambda at the point P what
is in our case x1 inverse theta phi okay
we now come in closer this expression
for a second and what we see this that
is exactly the derivative of this with
respect to the eighth come with respect
to the a entry and the enth component
but what we see here is if we derive the
first component with respect to
something else than the one component we
get a zero and we only get a one if we
derive with respect to theta with the
first component for the second term the
same argument holds if here is a two
here is a two so in total we can write
this guy here in matrix representation
as 0 1 1 1 0 0 1 a-m and this guy we
also can write 1 0 0 1 M B G M m h x3
lambda X inverse of theta phi ok after
that we see that this is just a delta so
we can just rename MN by a and B
a beam now we come back to the question
and I always forgot here to write down
that's Ellie whether these two things
are the same and what we see now is
since this guy here gives us in chart
representation nearly the same just
again of a theta and a fire but with an
offset in the second term only if the
offset I don't want to confuse it I just
calculate this by inserting this and
compare it with G a B le evaluated on
Theta Phi this this would be the most
easy thing because we already calculated
this I do it just for one component so
calculate this for one component it's
g11 le of h x3 lambda of X inverse of
theta 5 and this we calculate I think
one exercise before or in the same X I
think in the same exercise they were
already calculated the pullback of this
map
exactly and this was just a squared of
cosine Phi but now it's at cosine Phi
cosine Phi plus lambda here square again
times cosine square theta plus B squared
sine squared Phi plus lambda plus code
sorry times cosine squared theta plus C
squared time
silence queer theta this is what we
calculate now that's the poor back with
respect that the poor back of the Chi
ellipsoid with respect to this flow map
and what we had if you do not pull back
with respect to this flow map just the
poor back of the eyelid Ian's metric
with respect to the s2 we found out that
these are almost the same just with some
different expressions instead of Phi
plus lambda we have just fine that's all
the difference what we found out here
and he forgot term term it's cosine
square Phi DT comparing this two
expressions we see if a is equal to B
here just written a squared times cosine
squared of theta and here just written a
times 8 squared times cosine squared
theta
aha that means of a and B is the same
then the pullback of the cella period
along the edge ik 3 lambda curve is
again the Chi ellipsoid this also holds
for all the other components of Chi this
means if you have just a lip side
instead of this is ellipsoid and this is
a sphere and this is our angle Phi that
means if you just deform in this
direction then this map is again then
the x3 is a symmetry of the metric and
this is the idea of this exercise to see
that under which circumstances vector
fields are symmetries this concludes
this exercise and see on the next time